what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i have morning coffee thoughts and i do
not have coffee i have tea
but
i don't really drink that much coffee
anymore
i probably should this probably is as
much sugar as a coffee
anyways before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell the way you're going to be notified
of
my daily videos
so today i'm talking about
[Music]
apparently
i'm misogynistic who knew i hate myself
and i know you guys are saying well you
guys always tell me don't respond
but it's like
if i could make you a 10 minute video
about why you're wrong
who else gets to do that
and i get to make money off of it i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna do it so today
we're talking about
how they say i hate women and i'm
misogynistic and they'll give me a
couple examples stop breathing so loud
ellie we didn't even walk that far
we didn't even walk that far talk to my
dog okay
so so
let's get this out of the shot shouldn't
i
they'll say
they'll say it's because
i tell fat people they're fat
i'll tell men they're fat too
but like i'm not gonna go out of my way
if i just see a fat person walking down
the street but like why do i have to see
your rolls
look i don't even consider myself thin
enough to be wearing one of those bikini
things at the beach why you guys put me
through that i feel the same way about
girls that have their cheeks out why do
i have to look at your cheeks
why i don't like women
i know the men are like oh no don't tell
them to put them away
but me i'm like
i want to see your ass
i just came here to chill
so
what i've noticed is whenever i say yeah
men can have standards
this is what women do they'll be like
well
you're not that thin
my dad lived 300 pounds
i probably could be thinner you know but
you can't i'm not out of shape you y'all
can say what you want
i'm trying to lose that last 10 15
pounds i'm working on it not well
because i ordered a starbucks today but
i'm going running okay
but
i'm like
patricia you got more roles than i know
what to do with
stop stop talking about me but that's
what they do they shame you and they
insult you
or they find out i'm pro-life and i
don't believe in abortion and i say or
you could just not
have
sex with guys that you don't believe are
fathers or if you're gonna do that you
can wear a condom
well there's exceptions it's not that
black and white i'm so tired of women
saying the phrase it's not that black
and white
i remember
and i know it's funny because i have a
show called the gray area
look it
but
it's true guys
like we can make this better decision
and the part that bothers me
is instead of telling young women the
next generation of women
okay i met a girl that was a virgin the
other day and i wish to god that i
waited till i was married to have sex i
didn't right
but
and i'll tell my sisters like your
virginity is the most valuable thing you
can give to a man
and
like don't waste that with just anybody
and
don't
you know make sure that
either you're married or he loves you
and i i would go on more of the side of
like married but i know we're in a new
dating age that's different than it used
to be you know
so
you know do do without what you want but
like i just because i didn't do it like
i want the next generation of women to
like
no
north is north basically like that judge
says
because
a lot of times what i see is the girls
in their mid to late 20s trying to
compete with the like young 18 to 20 22
year olds
or even like their early 30s and so they
give them bad advice because they don't
want to be alone
misery loves company and it's not
misogynistic to say hey don't sleep with
a lot of dudes okay it's not
misogynistic to say hey you keep your
high school body
oh my god girls keep your high school
body because trying to get that [ __ ]
back takes forever
oh my god i've been working out for
years
years i know you guys are gonna don't
come from my starbucks i don't drink i
don't smoke this is my one thing my one
thing
look okay now
um
but that's what i'm saying right
like at least give the women the
information hey
i'm not saying you can't have any career
right i'm not even saying
have a traditional relationship but i'm
saying
these are the facts this is the data
this is the statistics do with it what
you may
but
apparently that's misogynistic
and that's the thing like at the end of
the day i like helping women i mean i i
advocate for men
but
my my my target is women because i think
there's a lot of women that if they're
given the right information they would
make better decisions
so
i don't know why they think that's
misogynistic what else do they say
because i say don't sleep around but men
can sleep around i don't even really
advocate for men sleeping around like
y'all
there's a level of purity you can't get
back and even as a man
like i think when there's a reason it's
when both the man and the woman are
virgins they have a longer marriage like
that's the happiest longest marriages
now
there's less consequences for a guy that
sleeps around and if anything he's
rewarded for it
but
yeah that's that's my like two cents on
that
i don't even tell that i just said i'm
just honest to girls and i just say
that guys can do it because we don't
care
girls can't do it because they care
and at least the girls can have this
information
and move accordingly
and
a lot of guys will put up with a lot if
you come at them in a different way in a
way that like you don't deserve them
but the problem is and even even single
mothers right
it's over for a lot of single mothers
because of the attitude that comes with
single mothers it's not necessarily
because they're single mothers there's a
lot of guys that will date girls with
kids
but
when you have
a sense of entitlement and you're a
single mom it's like
like i have family members that were
single that ended up being single
mothers they were ex like they used to
be married and then they became you know
then they were single and then they got
remarried but
like they didn't come at these men like
they're better than them like the person
i'm thinking of is very grateful for her
husband and like regards him very highly
so
i don't know
this is
my two cents my morning coffee thoughts
apparently i'm a misogynist
anyways let me know in the comments what
you think what you want my next morning
coffee thought to be goodbye